just tell me the wackiest craziest
[ __ ] story you got
well we'll end it with like a a crazy
[ __ ] story that'll blow people's
minds
and i can't yet because i don't know how
far i can go
you can go no this is a youtube video so
you can go oh here's
his wife you can go so [ __ ] far you
know
in nwa we did a lot of towns
and in the south there and you know the
the southern cops in a lot of these
little towns and that
there was one town where we used to do
tv
in um i can't even think of the name of
the town now
but we had to go through smaller towns
to get to it you know
do the tv there and the cops used to
wait for for the boys to come through it
to give them tickets you know what i
mean yeah it's it's one of those things
you're doing 65 55 45
and you come near the town it's 25 and
then it goes down to 15.
anyhow we're in we go through that town
and then we pick our speed and get out
of town and there's rotty piper me and
butch
we're drinking and and this is going
back
in early 80s having a couple of tokes
and that and um
a couple of toasts couple of bumps yeah
and then no no bumps no bumps that was
like the drug of choice back then the
cocaine yeah and
and that i heard some crazy cocaine
stories wrestling i can tell you
something too but i don't want to
tell because people are still alive okay
anyhow just use pseudonym names
uh anyhow um we get out we get on the
road there we just get out
out about 20 minutes away and the guy
had been following us we didn't know
and now we've put some speed up on that
and we get pulled over
yeah and the [ __ ] um the cobb was a
real
southern redneck cop and that blah blah
blah
he's says uh he says they're gonna take
you in
you you're caught at doing i think we're
70. we're doing 70
and a 55 mile he says and he said he
took the driver he said
follow me he says one of you is coming
he put one of us in the police car
and one of us had it was ronnie piper
driving
and we and we um take us back to the
little town and he took us back to the
courthouse
on the way back to the courthouse he
called the judge
the judge gets up and at the time we get
there
we're waiting outside the judge's home
is next doors the little courthouse
and it's one of these little towns you
blink as you go through it you know what
i mean
you blink as you go through it and um
we we wait for him he comes across from
his home
to the courtroom in a dressing gown and
slippers
lets us in and we go we sit in front of
the bench in that
and blah blah blah and he finds rodney
right there and then so much and if you
don't
and if you don't pay it then they take
your license
so they hold your license there until
you
until they pay it and um
and and you get your license back anyhow
i don't know what happened whether he
took the license
but we scraped up between the three of
us the the fine
i think or he took his slices anyhow
the hammer goes down the fine pay
we go to leave we go outside now he's
sitting at a table like this
right and it fits like that and about
where
those those things there's a window
where you've got your other
monitors there maybe closer half the
distance
and he's sitting here he's sitting at
his desk about here
and there's monitors there we come
around to that window there
and roddy gets up and pisses pisses all
over the window
he could turn like just like that and he
could see the piss hitting the window
and that and i i was freaking out and
funny
he didn't give a [ __ ] and he was pissed
i could imagine have he just turned
around and saw it he come out
we would have been locked up that night
oh my god that's [ __ ] insane
wow all right dude thank you thank you
for the stories luke that was awesome
i want to get some really good ones
here's one then
we're up and we're up in bangkok or
singapore
yeah and boogie street you know you sit
down boogie street's a market street
during the day
and at night it's market street people
walking up and down
and there's market and restaurants you
know with little restaurants
at night the street's closed off it's
notorious in the world
yeah this and all the hookers and
everybody else there
is on boogie street right there's little
tables
guys don't own restaurants and that but
they put a little table out with four
chairs
one guy might put one table out or two
tables out
and that's how he makes a living he
brings your menus from about four or
five restaurants around
so you you sit at his table and you
order booze
he'll go and get it all someplace and
then and he's got all the menus you
choose where
of what menu and you sit at his table
you know what i mean yeah he runs the
restaurant brings the menus over there
now he brings the menu with all the
girls on it yeah and there's all the
trinkets too on one
you know what i mean and the live shows
the dog shows the donkey shows and all
that
and he brings the menu over and and he
and uh we're looking through
the the uh the girls and that
you know we were living over there for a
hundred dollars a hundred dollars a week
we would have been like kings hundred
dollars away was it singapore singapore
yeah
uh this was this was 1969
i think and that's
1769 and that and was
what kind of girls what kind of girls
were on that menu oh
she males and males and females and
everything
damn we were living at have an apartment
overlooking the harbour
because singapore is a gateway to the
east all the container ships come in
there
and now we were smoking this weed and my
partner had never smoked a
thai stick before and that this is thai
steak stick
okay thai stickers you squeeze the buds
and juice strips out sounds heavy
and that oh yeah you hallucinate on it
we're sitting in an apartment
and that and there's all ranch sliders
and there's a balcony here overlooking
the harbour
and all the container trips container
ships are there
and the lights are flashing on them and
that and butch thinks there's a war
going on
out there with all the lights we've got
the big you know like you see in movies
the big wooden fans the props are about
you know this wide the big the wooden
they're like that they're that
that wide and they go like that let's go
he's thinking this helicopter is coming
in on us and everything he's freaking
out
you know i'm just telling you how we
were the first time he smoked thai stick
over there we were living on three
dollars worth of stuff a week
and that's crazy eating all our washing
and food was cooked for us
our washing was done every night the
clothes you take off
the housekeeper would come in early by
the time we got up all our clothes have
been washed what we wore the day before
we were living the life like king is
over there getting your ham
going in for a mess to get your hair
shampooed and that and hair done
you sit in a chair the woman would
massage your feet
and clean your feet and massage your
feet and trim your nails and all that
and then massage your head and and you
know shampoo you mess with your head and
your hands and trim your nails and that
and and um you'd be high as a kite
you know how much i'd pay for that three
dollars oh god damn yeah yeah this was
unreal and all these
all the mails you could ask for anyhow
butch points out this one on this
menu and boogie street and he says
that's her over there
and that so
we have a few drinks today we go over
there and uh we take
it we take these two girls home right um
back to the apartment yeah
butch's wife doesn't hear this anyhow
we go we're up in the apart or up in the
apartment all of a sudden
i hear a scream and which says [ __ ] i've
got a handful of [ __ ] rocks
oh no it was a guy
oh beautiful beautiful tips everything
and
i says [ __ ] it turn around and [ __ ] her
she's got big tits yes
what did he do did he do it i don't know
oh my gosh
yeah that's unbelievable that's insane
you've lived one hell of a life you know
they did that that was in singapore
bangkok was you've heard about banjo
yeah right yeah that's just like other
things crazy over there yeah yeah that's
a different live show i watched
i've seen donkey shows and all that sort
of stuff
where the girl comes out and that
with a girl and she can't get satisfied
then the guy comes out and then she
can't get satisfied
then they bring the donkey in the
harness oh my god and it's got a little
and it's got a rubber band and like a
little tube around it's
john thomas
so it can't go all the way in here you
know what i mean oh my god
and there's there's a harness the
donkey's in a harness you know what i
mean
she's she's in like this and they'd
lower the donkey down
oh my god holy same [ __ ]
because it gets wild in other countries
i'm talking about i'm talking about in
the 60s yeah
oh yeah anything probably went back then
you know the girls from new zealand
the drag queens from new zealand used to
go over to
singapore and or you know australia or
singapore
and they get the cut and tuck down there
you know cut
and tuck that was done over there a
little years ago the surgeons and that
and get it you know get all the they get
their
implants and all that sort of stuff you
know the ones that
work in australia new zealand when i was
now i don't know if this is true or not
but can you is it true what you used to
tell me at the gym about the sheep
she were you joking with me about the
woolly girls the woolly girls that's all
he goes what everyone said
the farmer will say sheep's [ __ ] is the
closest to a woman
the they call them wooly girls yeah the
woolly girls
sheep heard us we were called the sheep
shaggers the sheep jackers
is it true i don't know i ever checked
one oh i thought you did
i believed you no because you used to
say like the tongues are great
anymore somebody else the tugs agree
that's it yeah you got to keep them in
the morning
early to kiss them before their tongues
get green from grazing
[Laughter]
that's all you said you know when we
come in here
when we come over this side of the world
the people in the front seat will be
driving us
and they say what language you talk they
they couldn't understand me and butch
because we'd talk so fast in english